- We love to spotlight
amazing dads on this show.
And our next dad is a Halloween hero.
This is GDP, Good Dad Program.
(audience cheers)
Okay, this story comes out of Cincinnati,
where one brave dad engineered
a trick or treat solution
for the COVID age.
And here to tell us all about it,
please welcome Andrew Beattie.
(audience cheers)
- Hi Drew, how are you?
- Hi Andrew.
- Thanks for having me on the show.
- Oh, I was gonna say
the same thing to you.
Thank you so much for coming on.
Now, your story is getting
picked up everywhere.
So we're really lucky that you came
and will talk to us about it, and we-
- I feel like I'm the lucky
one, but thank you so much.
- Oh thank you Andrew.
Andrew, Drew, cool.
Anyway, I always do that with an Andrew,
and I love it 'cause my
name's like a boy's name
but I just get excited when I hear it.
So it's no surprise that the CDC
is like officially called
off trick or treating,
and they've called it
a high-risk activity.
But you have found a
way to lower the risks.
So will you tell us about it?
- Absolutely, I'd be happy to.
So my wife and I, we have a
six year old daughter at home,
and we really love doing creative things,
activities that we can do
together that are fun and safe.
And you know this year,
and really any year,
practicing safety guidelines
when trick or treating
is really important.
But especially with COVID-19 this year,
it was more important
than ever to give people
an opportunity to maintain those
social distancing guidelines
and have some fun with it along the way.
And this was something that we thought
would be a really great way to do so.
So we used a six foot by
four inch shipping tube
that we had laying around.
We had played with
dropping some toys down.
And my wife and daughter
and I painted it up orange,
put some black duct tape
around it and lit it up
and put it on our rail
to give it a test run.
And it just seemed to
really work really well.
- And people are freaking out about it.
And what I love is that you got something
so convenient and attainable.
This is not a Rube Goldberg contraption
that people cannot build.
It's like, this is doable for people.
And I have to say that I as a parent,
I feel sort of rattled when my kids ask me
how is Halloween gonna function this year?
Are we gonna get candy?
Are we gonna go trick or treating?
And I know for each sort
of area within our country
there are different sets of guidelines
and we're always trying
to overcompensate for our kids anyway.
And I think you've come up with something
that feels really safe
and doable for parents.
And you really put the
spirit back in Halloween
and made it a little less difficult
for us parents to navigate.
- Thank you so much.
You know, we really wanted to do something
that could allow everyone to participate,
even those with mobility challenges.
This is something that we've been
talking about doing for years.
You know, you have those
moms with strollers,
or your people in
wheelchairs that have to stop
and think about how they can participate
the same way other people do
without having to stop and think about it.
And that seems really unfair
to me with something like this.
So this is something that doesn't just
scratch that one inch, it's something that
really I think helps a lot of people
regardless of whether or not
we're dealing with a pandemic.
So thank you.
(audience cheers)
- I have to say, Andrew,
I think you're bringing
all the goodness to the name Drew today.
I'm honored that I get that moniker too,
because you really are bringing
the positivity and the functionality here
for my favorite holiday of
the year, by the way too!
Halloween, you don't have to travel,
you don't have family baggage.
You don't have to get a gift.
It's just the best, I love Halloween!
So thank you, Andrew.
- That's right.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, my pleasure.
- Okay everybody, thank you so much.
(upbeat music)